ANANT AGARWAL: Welcome to MITx.
MIT'S worldwide online
learning initiative.
We are delighted to have you join us for
6.002x Circuits and Electronics,
the inaugural course of MITx.
6.002x is the same as electronics
circuits course taken by MIT students
as the first course in an
EE or EECS major at MIT.
This course will help you make the
transition from physics to electrical
engineering.
In this course, you will learn about
a lot of fun things, including the
foundations behind many cool devices
such as the smartphone.
The course will be hard and we
want you to stick with us.
It is our hope that you will have
a lot of fun in this course.
Let me start by introducing
you to our team.
I am Anant Agarwal.
Like most MIT faculty, I have a wide
range of interests including a
fascination around chain saws.
GERRY SUSSMAN: Hello, I'm Gerry Sussman,
professor of electrical
engineering at MIT.
I've been a faculty member
here since 1973.
I build electronics, optics, computer
software, and I repair
watches as a hobby.
PIOTR MITROS: I'm Piotr Mitros.
I'm a research scientist at MIT.
And I was in charge of developing the
software infrastructure for MITx.
As a graduate student, I spent a lot
of time traveling around India,
Nigeria, and China mostly as part of
educational technology projects so I'm
very excited to be helping
out with this course.
ANANT AGARWAL: Whether we like
chain saws or watches, we are
all passionate educators.
We welcome your participation and any
feedback you might have to improving
the learning experience.
Let's get started.